hey guys listen we're going to talk
about the key foods on a ketogenic diet
okay and those relate to key nutrients
that you would need to consume now let's
start with vitamin C why do you invite
him in see on a ketogenic diet because
we want to repair all the damage from
the high levels of sugar and high levels
of insulin which by the way had to do
with the vision and the arteries and the
kidney and the nervous system vitamin C
is necessary for that it's also
necessary to heal insulin resistance now
a lot of vitamin C is in the vegetables
but people think that they're going to
consume lemon juice from a bottle and
pour it in the water and get all the
vitamin C but that's not true because
all the vitamin C that you buy on the
shelf is all pasteurized it's cooked
it's heated so you don't have any more
vitamin C left so if you're taking an
actual lemon and juicing that you're
getting some vitamin C but not from the
bottle now the advantage of consuming
lemon juice would be to counteract some
of the stones that could be developing
on a ketogenic plan but not necessarily
vitamin C okay bell peppers are loaded
with vitamin C especially the green bell
pepper okay all the peppers have a good
amount about even saying that bell
pepper is pretty darn high so that would
be a really good thing to consume
sauerkraut is another food that's real
loaded with vitamin C so every day if
you had just a half a cup that would
give you way more than you would need
okay but some people don't like
sauerkraut so go with the bell peppers
omega-3 fatty acids salmon make sure
it's wild-caught and fatty fish okay
loaded with omega-3 we want to make sure
this is very very high okay then we have
vitamin b1 and also other B vitamins but
b1 is the most important this is really
important because the need for B vitamin
goes up when you get into ketosis so
sunflower seeds are have a good amount
of b1 and they have other B vitamins as
well believe it or not pork has a good
amount of b1 some people don't like pork
that's fine I have the high quality
non-processed no sugar bacon so I
consume that some people don't like it
that's fine you don't have to do that
nutritional yeast is another
that's loaded with the b-vitamins okay
then we get to potassium magnesium these
are really important on a ketogenic diet
the way you get that is large quantities
of vegetable seven to ten cups a lot of
people don't like consuming their
vegetables you're gonna have to bite the
bullet and do that potassium is
necessary to heal insulin resistance and
it's involved in a lot of other things
magnesium is also at the heart of
insulin resistance as well as it's
actually in chlorophyll so anything
green like leafy greens and avocados and
dark leafy green vegetables you're gonna
get enough potassium so green vegetables
avocados beet tops have the most
potassium of anything I think it's per
cup it's like 13 hundred milligrams it's
off the charts and then avocados are
also loaded with it as well so we need
large quantities of these vegetables to
get the nutrients okay and then we have
iodine so this is another trace mineral
that's actually hard to get unless
you're consuming seafood unless you're
doing sea kelp an iodine is really
important for females with glandular
tissue with uterus with thyroid with the
balance estrogen very very important
okay and then we have iron red meat okay
or organ meat very important in
fortifying your blood so you can have
endurance okay then we have
phytonutrients what are phytonutrients
it's those plant-based chemicals that
give you additional health benefits that
go way beyond just vitamins and minerals
and trace minerals and amino acids and
fatty acids so if either nutrients are
anti-cancer anti astringent so they're
really good to clean the body and
protect yourselves against all sorts of
damage from the environment and to get
these you would want to consume sprouts
sprouts certain sprouts like broccoli
sprouts have about 50 times more thought
of nutrients and even just regular adult
vegetables so the combination of
vegetables and sprouts you're going to
be totally fine but we wanted to include
that just to you know as part of your
health creating eating plan alright
thanks for watching
hey guys I wanted to personally invite
you to a new Facebook group that I just
started called dr. Berg's Kido and in a
minute fasting lab okay so I created
this so we can share our successful
actions what worked what didn't work
your results so I put a link down below
so go ahead and sign up and I'll see you
inside